Vsauce Five Riddles, Four Most Expensive,
Three Oldest, Two Youngest and One Anamorphic
Painting
It's 5, 4, 3, 2...
One Anamorphic painting
The Worlds longest anamorphic painting according
to Guiness was created by British artist Joe
Hill of 3D Joe and Max and was unveiled at
West India Quay, London on Novemeber 17th
2011 to celebrate Guiness World record day.
It was 348 feet and 9 inches.
Two Youngest
Victor De Leon III AKA "Lil Poison" is the
world's youngest signed professional gamer.
In 2005 at the age of 7 he signed a deal with
Major League Gaming and set the record. He
started with the dreamcast at the age of two
playing NBA 2K and entered his first competition
in New York at the age of four, a Halo tournament.
Julian is the world's youngest professional
drummer as of March 21st 2012 when he was
5 years 10 months and 3 days old. He began
drumming on his father's lap at just 3 months.
At 15 months he was offered a contract to
be a member of the Cleveland cavaliers drumline
and at 20 months he recorded his first album.
Three oldest:
86 year old Johanna Quaas holds the record
for oldest gymnast. She performed a parallel
bar and floor demonstration at the 2012 Cottbus
Challenger Cup in Germany. She didn't even
take up gymnastics until she was 30 but now
regularly participates in senior gymnastics
competitions where she has won multiple awards.
The worlds oldest surviving photograph was
taken by Joseph Nicephore Niepce in 1826,
called "View from the Window at Le Gras".
The photo was lost for 50 years after being
exhibited in London and rediscovered by Helmut
Gernsheim in 1952 and is now typically on
display in Austin, Texas.
The oldest convicted bank robber was 92 when
he robbed a bank in Texas in 2003. J.L Hunter
Rountree, nicknamed "Red" pleaded guilty to
stealing $1,999 and was sentenced to 151 months.
It was his third and last robbery, his first
took place in 1998 at the age of 86. He claimed
that he was trying to get back at the banks
for the financial ruin they had put him in.
A documentary called "This Is Not A Robbery"
is based on his story.
Four Most Expensive:
Chris Evans a UK radio and television personality
has the record for buying the most expensive
car. He paid $17.7 million (12 million pounds)
for a 1963 Ferrari 250 GTO, one of only 36
ever made. It has a top speed of 174 MPH and
goes 0 to 60 in 6.1 seconds.
A bottle of 1947 Cheval-Blanc Bordeaux wine
set the record for most expensive wine sold
at auction for $304,375 on November 16th 2010
that crushed the expected price tag of $150,000
to $200,000.
In May of 2012 the record was set for Worlds
most expensive hot dog at Capitol Dawg in
Sacramento, Cal for $145.49. It's called the
California City Capitol Dawg and includes
Swedish Moose cheese that has to be flown
in and goes for $200 a pound. Since then there
have been some more expensive hot dogs that
technically don't hold the record yet. At
New Yorks 230 Fifth they created a $2300 hot
dog that includes 60 day dry aged Wagyu beef
topped with onions caramelized in Dom Perignon
and 100 year old balsamic vinegar, sauerkraut
braised in Champagne and mixed with caviar
and topped with Gold.
The Red Tibetan mastiff holds the record for
the most expensive dog ever sold. The 11 month
old puppy named Big Splash or "Hong Dong"
in Chinese sold for 10 million yuan or $1.5
million in China by a breeder in 2011. Hong
Dong weighs in at 180 pounds and is three
feet tall. In related news the newest record
holder for tallest dog is a great dane named
Zeus from Michigan that is 7 foot 4 on his
hind legs!
Five Riddles
Mad Gabs are a group of words that don't make
sense until you say them slowly and discover
the hidden phrase or name. For example:
Ape Hick Cheer Rail Bum is... A Picture Album
Here are three Mad Gabs.
Dawn Tall Quit Chore Mile Full
Ask Rude Arrive Her
Debt Snot Must Aisle
Here's a visual puzzle...
Which comes next in this series?
Here's a riddle from you guys.
In a chicken pen, each hen can see twice as
many cockerels as hens. Each cockerel can
see the same number of cockerels as hens.
How many chickens are in the pen?
Before we go here's last videos winner. Leave
your answers in the comments below.
And as always - thanks for watching!